figure one the horse
this is a story about a horse
a horse whose fate was inextricably tied
to the invention of film and it all
started with an innocent question do all
four of a horse's hooves
leave the ground at any point during a
gallop
leland stamford yes the dignified chap
who founded stanford university
thought they did
all four of a horse's hooves leave the
ground while galloping but some other
academics thought they didn't one foot
is most certainly always touching the
ground so to put the matter to rest
stanford hired a professional
photographer edward muybridge to capture
the truth on film
there was a bet
thousands of dollars were at stake as
well as a man's reputation
but wait
cameras at the time could not capture
things moving quickly there was no such
thing as a movie camera in 1878
so muybridge had to get creative
he devised an ingenious solution
12 wire triggers and 12 shutters for 12
cameras all evenly spaced to capture a
horse and carriage on a racetrack
the carriage was driven across the
tripwires setting off all 12 cameras in
less than half a second
capturing
the truth
you can clearly see all four hooves have
left the ground
leland stamford was right but honestly
we don't really care about the horse
what we do care about however is
muybridge's newfangled contraption used
to photograph things in motion
see what i'm getting at here
thomas edison and the lumiere brothers
certainly did they took muybridge's
invention and changed the course of
media as we know it
creating
the motion picture
as for the academics who lost the bet
they're fine
they had tenure
[Music]
you